welcome inside thrilled to have you with
us Jimmy Rollins J roll Curtis
Granderson Mark D Roa my name is Lauren
shahadi uh you are all smiles because
the Phillies follow the script were used
to seeing score early tack on late Jimmy
arms for days they did everything they
needed to do to Come Away with the win
and give themselves a chance to close
out at home with the guy they want on a
bump pitching that ballpark it was a
wellplayed game uh I I felt on both
sides it was just Philly kind of they
not that they kind of showed up they
showed up tonight uh much more calm not
going out there trying to do too much
they knew they had to go out there and
battle Zach they did that Kyle schwarber
what did we decide he eats for breakfast
Nails Nails a perfect script for Rob
Thompson right there perfect script they
steal two runs in the first the double
steal catches them out of Swords wheeler
adds to his postseason prowess two
superstars go deep you don't use
Alvarado was a good night for the Philly
yeah it was because they're six and0 at
the bank it is the definition of
HomeField Advantage right we've seen it
all postseason Hey Ron Darling said it
you know this was a more of a must-win
game for Arizona it's going to be almost
impossible to try to get two in Philly
and now I mean you've put all the
pressure on it but Philly did exactly
what they needed to do jump out early
continue to pitch play defense behind
close it out do exactly what they've
been doing how does anyone hit Zack
Wheeler it was down and then he would
Elevate when he walked Corbin Carol I
had to take a double take I'm thinking
he does not do that it was pretty darn
good the broadcast said he's the best
pitcher in the postseason
yes this year left in it for sure all
right absolutely across the board how
lucky are we we only have to wait one
day until we get to see game six of this
series first pitch is Monday and if
there is a game seven of the ALCS join
us at 4:30 for a 5:00 p.m. Eastern first
pitch if we are the only game in town we
will see you at 7:30 Eastern Jimmy you
copy you follow it I got you for an 8:00
game I'm sure you watched every single
second of game five if you missed a
thing Michael Phelps are you kidding me
how cool is that remember waking up in
the middle of the night to watch him go
for gold every single year time Devon
Brook Booker and Kevin Durant taken in a
ball game in the desert this is what the
Phillies do all day long score early
yeah they do Bryson stock Kyle schwarber
by the way hit the ball two feet he got
on first base and Bryson St knocked him
in making it one nothing early on you
know what they say about his Lauren what
do they say location location location I
thought you were going to say they're
contagious R was going by the way takes
off to Steel second on the throw a
second Bryce Harper coming home beauty
of that play Bryson sto stopping half we
halfway between second and first base
right there just kind of bait and Har
take home PL that's why I kind of Wonder
like why even throwing that situation I
know you have one of the best throwing
catchers in all of baseball but you got
to understand that they're trying to
steal a run right there he's not trying
to steal second base but I'm sure they
didn't have that in mind either Gabriel
called beforehand right yeah checked out
Bryce making sure he's okay best sign
he's okay single up the middle bottom of
the first one out got him Corbin Carroll
goes back to Second by the way only able
to advance to third maybe I missed that
that was big maybe it for sure was
because Zach wheeler just goes to work
Christian Walker and then paven Smith
grounds out to end the inning he's like
get out of here I don't think a
right-handed hitter had an any chance
for the Diamond Backs tonight he had 95
to 97 sinking in elevated for seamer and
the best breaking ball we've seen him
have tip of the cat to Bryson sty watch
this all his momentum taking him the
other way doesn't matter beautiful play
throwing out lordis guriel Jr Philly's
up to to nothing think he can play
second Jim Curtis I like to point this
out that he was a short stop he can play
short yeah he played Short last year
inil they took over today and another
one a gold glove finalist for a reason a
nice stop and a throw out catel Marte to
end the inning short stop so you know
who you don't want to beat you he's one
of them let me take you back this was
game one oh
GS lay back clipped him on the first
pitch and then Bryce Harper got his to
don't I mean game one was over before it
even
started by the way what did gallon throw
schwarber first pitch because that was a
big debate the pregame show cut her up
okay fast forward to tonight Zach gall's
like
Uncle that is as middle of the box as it
right down the middle don't mind if I do
a knuckle curve 80 mil distance on that
ball forever I'll take it you know
what's funny we kept saying oh the balls
aren't carrying the balls aren't
carrying the big boys for sure top of
the sticks I think that one came with a
storus nobody loves this month more than
Bryce Harper seven pitches in this at
bat for seamer got him is it me but his
finish the way he he he kind of stops
and stands up it reminds me of Reggie
Jackson when he used to Club him and
just kind of stand there and let you
know Alec Thomas the hero in game four
two-run shot to tie the score
he said he watched it over and over
again we chatted with him in batting
practice today 4-1 Phillies Bryson stop
bottom of the seventh we get it diving
stop short stop but he made the play in
the Outfield though so he started with
his feet in the
dirt try to figure out you've done
both you've been on both sides of Short
Stop appreciate you bro I'm sorry JT
real What's this called what's it called
ding dong Insurance two run shot the
first two shot Lauren it's okay if you
say ding dong John
first that's so true Curtis it's a good
point because the Phillies were only one
for six with runners in scoring position
they were living off the solo shot so a
happy flight for the Phillies back home
uh to their people and Phillies out hit
Arizona 9 to7 Matt Wier postgame
catching up with Zack Wheeler at the
star of the
game Zack second straight Dom Min start
in this series 35 swings and misses over
the two start 16 strikeouts how did you
approach the second time around here on
their
Turf um just got to stay Within Myself
don't try to do too much it's a big game
for us get that momentum back um you
know help out the bullpen so that's my
goal today is try to go deepest possible
good quality Innings you're putting up
some historic sort of postseason numbers
at this point in your career why do you
think you've been able to consistently
meet these moments I don't know I'm just
trying to pitch the best I can uh you
know thankful for uh you know the staff
um the guys playing defense behind me JT
behind the plate defense was
unbelievable tonight that saved me and
uh you know bat stepped up as a pitcher
how much can you appreciate what the
opposition is going through against a
lineup that can wreak the kind of Havoc
they have on the base paths and put
baseballs way up there wherever short is
landed yeah yeah I mean you know har
schw um you know we scored some runs
tonight we did it that was just home run
so it's nice and then uh you know the
the keep the guys off the base they're a
speedy team um you know if they do get
on you got to pay attention to them so I
was trying to do the best I could with
that I'm sure you noticed Philly was
well represented here tonight Monday
night you guys get the real thing with a
chance to go to the World Series how
good do you feel with Aaron Nola on the
mound Noah's got to do it he's going to
step for us um you know he has all
playoffs and uh you know this got to
have on the mou Zach thanks we'll see
you in Philly thank
you what's the message because it's it's
not going to be easy going back there
they've got this amazing record best in
MLB history the fan base y y what's the
message to keep the guys fighting yeah
um first of all we're very respectful of
where we're going and and the team that
we're playing but um you know once again
we got to put on us on our Dugout our
clubhouse and just go and do the things
that we do best we made some mistakes
today um and we didn't capitalize in
some key situations and that was the
difference in the game um we know we
know what's ahead of us we know um
either way we were going back to Philly
and we're going to have to win baseball
games there um but I don't want to think
about game seven because anything can
happen in a game seven setting um we got
to go out and play our best game in in
game six we got a very tough pitcher
that we're going to be facing but once
again I'm going to put on our our group
um I believe in Marl Kelly I Believe In
the guys that go out there in next
and play at a higher level and make make
plays and do things right Tor take us
through the uh first inning the double
steal I know you practice that a lot
just expecting Marte to be able to make
that throw yeah um for sure you gotta we
work on that a lot I think if we just
play pitch and catch and and he drives a
throw in the home plate and gives Gabby
a chance to catch up ball and and lay
the tag down on Harper he's out by 8 10
feet so um you know you're trying to
collect an out right there and get off
the field one down one one nothing um he
just short off The Catcher And and that
type of stuff happens from time to time
but um the play didn't surprise us we
were anticipating it it was well timed
by our guys we just didn't finish the
play he said we didn't capitalize what
ises that mean to you because over and
over again watching this game Corbin
Carroll was on first base we were
screaming right Dro we were screaming at
the TV go go go that's been their game
pressure on the base paths all season
long why is it different now yeah I I
would love to know in those meeting
rooms why it has changed a little bit
you had to know coming into this series
you're the underdog right not overmatch
but the underdog walking into this
series so you're going to have to do
things a little bit differently you're
going have to put pressure I mean it's
the ultimate respect to Zack Wheeler and
JT real Muto not to run but at the same
time I'm watching the guy Gabby Moreno
behind the dish he could throw out guys
with the best of them Philly still
they're trying to steal bags and take
the game to the Diamondbacks I just feel
like they're waiting for that big knock
against wheeler and we talked about this
in the postseason when you're facing a
guy like wheeler you're hoping somebody
runs into one yeah you're not stringing
you're not stringing three knocks
together so you have to get aggressive
and try some things and if if it's not
stealing maybe they don't feel
comfortable they don't want to run into
an out the hit and run is still a great
play that team puts the ball in play
with the best of them but it puts action
it puts something get everybody moving
move the defense around kind of stir
some things up but again we don't
understand what's happening prior to
because you're being told as the runner
hey you're either green meaning you can
go or we're red and we're waiting for
something else to happen we don't know
exactly what's going on in that
situation how much tougher is it to
steal a base when everyone expects you
to do it because you were that guy o um
it it it does because they pay a little
more attention to you but the way the
game is played today with the the two
disengagements I'm trying to at least
draw one throw I want to extend my lead
just to get him over a little bit get
one throw off now I'm 50/50 what is he
going to do if he comes off a second
time I'm it's nothing to think about I'm
getting a big lead and going but when
it's your game and it's expected I
expect that of myself too they know I'm
going I'm up for the challenge I'm going
to get to a point where I'm comfortable
I'm safe I'm looking for my keys we
talked about it a couple days a couple
days ago what am I keying on is it is it
his body is he stiff when he goes to the
plate is he relaxed when he's coming
over is there something in the in his
back me what is my key and I'm finding
that cuz that's going to be the
difference between me being safe and out
now one thing know Dro you managed in
the world baseball class so put your
manager head on does anything change
we're Runners we're down 20 now it's not
even it's not a tie score game we're
behind do we get a little bit more
passive in that situation no I think you
got to get aggressive and read the room
right there because wheeler Dominate and
I'm looking at the
lineup Christian Walker struggling to
put the ball in play right now he's been
one of your big like kind of like gives
the shooter when he gets the second bit
he kind of gets those boys rolling Longo
got dropped to the E hole your
right-handers are having a a heck of a
time guriel trying to put some solid
wood on the baseball I just think Corbin
Carroll has kind of changed the entire
Dynamic of who the Diamondbacks are he's
going to be the unanimous national
league rookie of the year and maybe
there's something we don't know maybe
there's a little tweak there and they
don't want to run but it just seem it
just seems a little odd that that was
their game they were second to the
Baltimore Orioles in all of baseball in
running and also wonder One Thing how
much does analytics coming to play
because we know they don't value Sten
base as much and now we're in a
postseason and we don't want to take a
chance of giving up an out on a stolen
base when we have guys that can swing
it's one swing can tie the game that's
what I'm thinking they're such an
analytical team we're losing we can't
would have been the hold no one expected
us to be here yeah well they do say that
I was in that last playing with house
money where just's Go I mean they just
saw wheeler and Wheeler navigated them
perfectly you saw him in aball when he
was early in his career what did you
think then I went down in 2011 to San
Jose did a rehab assignment for the
Giants and this guy was on the bump and
I was playing behind him I went back up
to Bo and said uh I think there's a guy
in aball might need to be in our
rotation now he got traded for Carlos
beltron that year to the Mets ended up
signing a 5-year deal with the Phil
Lauren he's the closest thing we have to
Jacob deg Grom and I know Jacob deg
groh's been damaged goods here for the
last couple minutes he's a bull whip
he's a human bull whip on the mound it's
very free and easy for him to create
this Spin and and the rise in his four
seamer the two seamer is diving all over
the place he's got great extension he's
6'5 6'6 it looks like he's handing the
ball to JT real Muto then throw in the
fact that he had complete dominance of
his breaking stuff you can call it
whatever you want slurve sweeper curve
they're all Morphin into one he had
different shapes all night and there was
nothing they could do to stop it and you
mentioned like he's the closest to the
gr I was with the Mets when we had that
five-headed horse with deg Grom and
mattz and syart and Harvey and oh yeah
wheeler was right there then all of a
sudden becomes free agency wheeler goes
to the Phillies I think there was part
of that that added that chip to his
shoulder two go everyone talked about
everybody else over there what about me
now it's my chance I'm getting a chance
to show everybody it helps when his
offense gives him support how the heck
you pitching to Kyle schwarber and Bryce
Harper not down the middle we saw it but
they're not chasing either Jimmy no they
weren't um they did what they wanted to
do and that was the opposite of what
they did last time they weren't looking
to Ambush they were looking to try to
get pitch to hit maybe you know see how
he was going to approach them cuz
obviously he couldn't go out them the
same exact way and when he made a mist
mistake they made him pay we saw early
on he hit the ball 5T and took the
single later on a hanging breaking ball
and it doesn't get any sweeter than that
those balls come off the bat like those
little uh rubber balls when you us to
play paddle ball it just bounces there's
only one thing for that ball to do and
that's go a long ways and Bryce right
there he pitched them tough I mean he
was making pitches but the Phillies
weren't as aggressive they weren't up
there freely swinging they were looking
for balls in zones and when they when he
finally made that
mistake they made him pay and right
there oh my gosh that's the problem
that's when just so it's pretty and
violent oh look at that that if I could
have done that I would have hit about
500 myself Bry just continuously has the
ability to change the room all the time
I had him at 19 when he first came up
with the Washington Nationals in 2012
and when he walked in the room we knew
the best player on the team just walked
in
at 19 I mean obviously he was going to
make some mistakes but to just be around
him he's lived a different life than any
big league ball players ever lived and
he's lived up to it has anyone
ingratiated themselves to a fan base
more in this game with the ftic cleats
and the jacket and he's he's dialed de
he's uh he's he's doing everything right
but what he's doing the most right what
he's playing Bryce Harper baseball in
Philadelphia hey the visiting team won a
game in this series for the first time
by the way just figure that out